[Music]
the redness would descend and he would
attempt to intimidate by bullying and
that is inexcusable that's what I call
that total and utter rubbish from start
to finish don't think that in school he
was involved in that radicalization
I just think that he lacked a father
figure tonight in each of all failing to
apologize is now beatable
there are they still in it's pretty hard
but hopefully it'll be worth it to kind
of get on result I've got a lot more
competitions and to my belt more worlds
more gyros just my experience praised by
some demonized by others John Burke has
timers speaker was as divisive as the
Parliament he oversaw his departure from
the Commons has been as controversial as
his time in the chair with the
re-emergence of claims that he bullied
common staff first of all I absolutely
insist that I have never bullied anyone
anywhere at any time
secondly the overwhelming majority of
the working relationships that I had
over the years as a member of parliament
as Speaker in the constituency office in
the speaker's office and the staff
across the house were positive and
fruitful relationship
we interviewed David Leakey in last week
I know you you're aware of the
allegations but let's just remind the
audience again there is what is what the
former black rod had to say my opinion
is that he brutalized
staff in the House of Commons and
elsewhere might include myself in that
and I think he brutalized is a good word
for what he did to Lord less pain his
private secretaries David not slur the
Clark who took over from Lord less vain
John Benji the Clark who's taken over
from him as well and they have all told
me in private moments and some of their
experiences at the hands of John Bercow
my view is that he brutalized people
right and it wasn't just those top
people it was people much further down
the pecking order and he tried to do it
with others politicians as well who went
into his office brutalized his the word
used three times I think it's all an
utter rubbish from start to finish I
noticed how hesitant David Lee he was in
developing his case as though he was
choosing his words carefully total utter
rubbish first point is that David Lee he
didn't work for me he wasn't employed by
me he wasn't an employee of the House of
Commons
he worked in and was the protocol
officer of the House of Lords he is in
absolutely no position whatsoever to
comment on my relations with my
parliamentary colleagues of which he is
completely and utterly ignorant he
doesn't know what my relations were with
my Clark's he has absolutely no
intelligence on those matters whatsoever
what we've got here is somebody who left
the house who is thrashing around
desperate to remain relevant popping up
at every turn trying to make himself
seem very important very center stage
very heart of things in the way that I
went about my work none of those things
Dermot is true absurdly preposterous Lee
he's turning up years later a couple of
years after he left the house commenting
on matters that he can't possibly know
about because he'd already left the guy
is a know nothing he hasn't a foggiest
idea what he's talking about
he was deeply hostile to me he's
entitled to his views but on the matter
of bullying he suffers from the
disadvantage of being one
percent wrong amen
he says you never work together and your
comments should be dismissed
well I the first thing to say is that I
stand by my allegations John burka of
course is perfectly entitled to protest
his innocence and dismissed them and
that's a perfectly normal reaction and
he says I didn't work for him well I
didn't work for him directly I was
employed by the House of Lords as he
pointed out in his interview but I think
he's either forgotten or was ignorant of
the role of black rod and about 30% of
my work was done in within for or on
behalf of the House of Commons so I had
very regular dealings with officials
senior and junior officials he tried to
intimidate me he did it to other people
he should be called out this is the if
you like her sort of Parliament me too
me too moment upon occasions the red
mist would descend and he would attempt
to intimidate by bullying and that is
inexcusable that's what I've called that
do you think he should be up here I
think it would be a scandal that
Parliament would struggle to live down
because he is in my view hasn't met the
integrity test which is the integrity
test applied by the House of Lords
Appointments Commission which says that
if a potential peer if the conduct
previous conduct of a potential peer is
likely to bring the House of Lords into
disrepute
then that must cast some doubt over his
appointment a nice polite boy who was
always smiling
it's how the mother of 20 year old
terrorist Sudha Sherman described him
holding back her tears while speaking to
Sky News off-camera
Halima Feroz Khan described how she
visited her son last week and said I
spoke to him on Sunday just hours before
he carried out his attack his mother
believes he became more religious inside
prison and he was watching and listening
to things on the computer which
brainwashed him
this was a man under police surveillance
because of his previous terror offenses
a former classmate of Sir - spoke to Sky
News about their time at high school he
was quiet he had his own little friend
group he stuck to it they didn't really
mix with you know many other people
outside the friend group and you know he
was just just seem like a pretty normal
student don't think that in school he
was involved in that radicalization I
just think that he lacked a father
figure and I think that he just ended up
taking the wrong path after high school
joined now by NHSN who has led an
independent review of Islamist extremism
in prisons in 2016 Ian's good afternoon
to you thank you for joining us we've
got a problem with the menu of
interventions that are on the table at
the moment and they are clearly not
being used and deployed to tackle some
of the hit for toxic ideologies that
motivate people like the the Stratham
attacker or Roseman can I think there is
probably quite a lot more that can be
done so I wouldn't want to give up yet
on the idea that we can reduce the
dangerousness of people I've stopped
really talking about D radicalization
it's a fairly meaningless concept people
aren't binary you don't flip them on and
off like a light switch and radicalize
them or D radicalize them it's a much
more complicated process than that but
while we are going to release the vast
majority of terrorist offenders who are
in custody at the moment into the
community we have to do everything that
we can to reduce the level of risks that
they posed and we also and I think you
know the here's where I would agree with
the independent reviewer of terrorist
legislation mark Rowley and other
professionals who have commented today
we also have to accept but in some cases
there are people whose world view is so
dangerous and so lethally unchangeable
that they must be kept in prison
indefinitely and the rights of citizens
to be protected from murderous outrages
like have taken place on London Bridge
and on streatham high road must be
prevented from happening if necessary by
keeping a small number of people whose
risk can't be reduced in
prison indefinitely one person who was
traveling on an evacuation flight from
Wuhan has fallen ill the passenger who
self isolated immediately was taken to
an NHS hospital for tests when the plane
landed well ten other people entered
quarantine on the world after the flight
from the epicenter of the outbreak of
coronavirus in China the nucleus
arriving on a second repatriation flight
into RAF Brize Norton last night they
draw an eighty three people already
isolated in staff accommodation at arrow
Park Hospital or the patient who fell
ill on that plane Anthony May Smith
joins us now via Skype addley
welcome to the signals signals not
brilliant but appreciate you talking to
us today you self isolated I mean that's
the way we're describing this tell us
what happened to you on the flight yeah
so went through a load of checks at the
airport and we had a bit of a cough and
a sore throat there and then there was
the elbows on that flight to France so
that put in quarantine section on the on
the flight to France when we boarded the
plane in France to come to the UK you
know some Paul just asked anybody if
they presented any any sauce and Susan
in China and I just made myself known to
her and she just basically told me to
sit away from everybody else on the on
the flight back so you know those people
were babies on on the flight and she
didn't want to be anywhere near them
really know just in case you know even
there being in a confined space really
sure it's just probably the stress of
getting back and just being run down
more than anything everything's okay
today yeah just waiting for the test
results come up hopefully tomorrow yeah
and you know people have this image of
quarantine these isolation how are just
easier I mean how grueling not very I
imagine but you know some worry whoever
comes into the room is a fully
protective of a face mask
all covered up about four pairs of
gloves Wellington's and everything like
that but puffs nice it's not too bad
just being kept away from everybody in
the hospital on my own at the moment
yeah it's hard to appreciate somebody's
bedside manner when they were a full
hazmat suit
I work in terms of getting out of Wuhan
how keep I mean clearly you know people
wanted to get home that's understandable
there was an argument that sometimes
runs the the best place for people is to
abstain in war han rather start
traveling and run the risk potentially
then spreading the virus yeah to be
honest that was the it was touch and go
whether I was gonna make fly on Saturday
night anyway you know it's really last
minute call off the embassy so they've
managed to transfer that and you know
the time was starting to consider myself
just staying there and just just riding
out really and then seeing how ill some
of the people were on the flight on the
way back and definitely you know I
thought maybe that was the wrong wrong
choice to come back now and you know
there's over 200 people on the flight to
France so only takes one person of that
swapping you potentially got another 230
people to court
[Music]
Hollywood is gearing up for the 92nd
Academy Awards this Sunday and once
again the Oscars are the subject of
concerns about diversity just one of the
nominees for Best Actor actress is not
white and no women have been nominated
in the best director category one part
of the Oscars which will break new
ground however is on the musical front
conductor Emma noone will become the
first woman in the history of the awards
to direct and conduct the orchestra that
plays during the ceremony how do you
feel to be the first woman to conduct at
the Academy Awards well I I feel
wonderful I think you know some people
say it's a long time coming but it's
here and I think to to credit these two
amazing women who are producing the show
this year does at Howell Taylor from
Liverpool and Stephanie Elaine their to
absolute power houses in the film world
and part of their shining moment there
they're handing to another colleague to
another woman and it's just it says a
lot about who they are and their
philosophy and the way they operate in
our creative industry I watched one
interview with you Emma where you said
maestro is everything you can do I've
done seven months pregnant and in heels
do you feel that you have to justify
yourself in that way well you know what
I love a bit of humor and I think I
think conducting is difficult no matter
what and you know I now at the age that
I matter
I have several wonderful wonderful women
colleagues who I love I love their work
I love hearing what they're doing and of
watching what they're doing but when I
was growing up that just that role model
wasn't really there for me and I think
you know it's it's again it's another
one of those complex roles but yes I
have toured pregnant yes I have have
conducted in heels and I will conduct in
heels on Sunday knives
and you know I've read things that the
conductor's have said about stamina and
and rubbish things and I have this is I
ain't being distracted by an attractive
woman on the podium yes that's
completely unhelpful for me the world
needs diverse artists because there's
richness and diversity there's richness
and getting to know the story of a
different artist every single one of us
is of course completely different and to
say to throw 50 percent of the
population into one category in the arts
is ridiculous frankly you know so it's
hopefully little by little these tiny
little gestures will you know will
snowball will will will pool into an
awareness or or a complete normalcy
President Trump has launched a scathing
attack on his opponents in his first
comment since his acquittal in the
impeachment trial he's been speaking
uninterrupted and without a script for
40 minutes now to an audience of
supporters in the White House we went
through hell unfairly did nothing wrong
I've done things wrong in my life I will
admit not purposely but I've done things
wrong but this is what the end result is
[Applause]
Donald Trump's defense team init
impeachment trial was Alan Dershowitz
the harvard law professor and he joins
us now thank you very much indeed
for being with us I mean convicted or
not Alan Dershowitz should the President
of the United States have apologized in
the speech that he's making now well
that's for the voters to decide voters
can look at what he did look at the
transcript of his speech and decide to
vote against him or for him I'm a
liberal Democrat I voted against him but
it's not impeachable and failing to
apologize is not an eatable
when they say you're a Democrat was this
whole thing in your view a strategic
error by the Democrats a terrible
strategic error and I think Nancy Pelosi
understood it and she was pressured into
moving toward impeachment by the radical
elements of the party the Corbyn
elements of the party to talk about a
British reference and she made a
terrible blunder and it hurt the
Democrats had helped the Republicans and
as a Democrat a liberal Democrat I'm
appalled at the way the Democrats have
shot themselves in the foot look a big
story here is Prince Andrew now you once
represented Jeffrey Epstein I know
Prince Andrew met him yeah but a huge
pressure on the Prince to start
cooperating with the FBI over these sex
trafficking allegations should he now
cooperate with the FBI I think he should
only think if he does you'll prove that
his accuser is a fervent liar who was
lied about Al Gore tipper gore Bill
Clinton me
majority leader of the United States
Senate Leslie Wexner she's made false
accusations about many many people this
is a woman I never met never heard of no
evidence she has emails with me
admitting that she never met me that she
never saw me she never knew me and yet
she makes a false story so I think if he
began
to cooperate as I have it would put the
lie to her while deadly chemicals are
routinely being used in countless
household products in spite of the fact
that the manufacturers know the risks
they pose that is one of the claims from
the lawyer Rob a lot who spent the last
20 years taking on the industry his
story has been made into a new film dark
waters released here later this month
that chemicals I'm telling ya I'm seeing
documents I'd understand they're hiding
something they're chemical what if you
drank it drank it that's like saying
what if I swallow a tire see first of
all you'll have seen the movies is it
largely accurate about about what you
went through over the past 20 years yes
I think they did a fantastic job of
taking a pretty complex story you know
that spans a long period of time and did
a fantastic job condensing it and really
really putting it together in a way I
think that conveys to people what it was
really like for the communities that
were involved in this and what it was
like to to go through this over the last
20 years to get this information out to
the rest of the public in essence the
story is that dupe on one of the world's
biggest chemical companies was knowingly
poisoning the local community in West
Virginia through the water supply and in
the air that's right it was a chemical
called PFOA that was used in their
manufacturing of Teflon in West Virginia
that was being emitted out into the Ohio
River into the air for decades and we
were able to figure that out through
this case and then realized was that the
chemical wasn't just there in West
Virginia was in the entire communities
drinking water and then we realized it
was in water all over the country all
over the planet in the blood of
virtually every person now on the planet
what comes out very clearly in the film
is that this really was that David and
Goliath struggle and and took an
enormous toll on you personally and your
family yes and I think what you also see
in the film is just the incredible
courage of Wilbur Tennant the farmer in
West Virginia who was able to stand
on behalf of his community and say this
is happening let's you know and took on
DuPont and it took a toll on him and on
that entire community this went on for
many many years
I mean you your corporate law you know
about this I mean the message is
certainly in the United States the dice
are really stacked against the
individual when it comes up against a
powerful corporation unfortunately very
much so and you know what we we had to
do here the community itself had to
actually come together we had 69
thousand people that provided blood
samples medical records in order to do
the health studies to confirm what this
chemical did to them
meet Peggy
and meet le sisters both One World
Championship medals in 2019 both could
medal at Tokyo talented siblings her
were straight I'm very very organized
probably over the top and Elly's not as
much I'd say I had organized but Becky's
just like next level organized every
time like if you wake up and you tired
all you saw in your eyelid I really want
to today it's like well why do you want
to be in seven eight months time and and
that's kind of like what keeps me
pushing what keeps me motivated what
keeps me working if there's going to be
days when it's like really hard there
are they still and it's really hard but
hopefully it will be worth it to kind of
get on resort bars it's probably the
only apparatus and women's right now
which is open to to win which is amazing
for me but that's my event first time
around I was probably less nervous and
anxious because I've never made it
before so this time I'm obviously
wanting to make the team and do a lot
better than I did
I've got a lot more competitions under
my belt more worlds more years just more
experience
[Music]